your fans all have their favorite
Stephen King books do you have hope
would they do or else they wouldn't be
fans what are your top five books or
short stories of Stephen King well I
think maybe the my favorite short story
would be called Survivor type which was
about a physician who gets stranded on a
little island and he's smuggling heroin
he's starving so he eats himself piece
by piece
so I like it for the whole family okay
one I like Misery the novel misery a lot
that was kind of fun
um it was a fun book to write
this is like you know Led Zeppelin
concert sort of like
Play Free Bird I'm like lisy story very
much
it's a series that's now streaming on
Apple Plus and there was one called uh
Stand By Me the body and
and Billy Summers the current one yeah
and Billy Summers